hey everybody and welcome to a major
wild ride with stevo what are we doing
here on the beach
you don't worry about that folks okay
what i'm talking about is we got my dad
this week and remember
what do you think what do you think of
my dad your dad is
one of the raddest dudes i remember back
when we were knuckleheads i told this
story before
yeah and your dad sat you me aside and
said dudes
don't blow your money don't buy no homes
wait five years
and i always listen to that and that's
when i bought my first big house
was right when your dad said to wait
five years
thanks pups you sold it for more than
double ladies and gentlemen because my
dad is the man
now we're starting this episode off in a
special way okay
because it was what 2019
about two years ago exactly when i tried
to record my very first ever podcast
this is my first attempt at podcasting
and i'm gonna play a minute and a half
of that first effort
and then we're gonna kick into the new
one
so let's get into it real quick dad
how about if we give everybody uh an
overview tell us about your career
yourself started my corporate career
in toronto and we moved around the world
a number of different
major companies procter campbell pepsico
uh rj reynolds tobacco del motti foods
uh nabisca brands and campbell soup
you lived in what four different
countries by the time
five different four different countries
by the time you were three
five different countries by the time you
got to high school and by the age of
three you'd spoken three languages
fluently
as i understand it you were president of
all of pepsi cola
and all of brazil when i was six months
old
that's correct it was the ideal size
profit center for one's first experience
as general manager
ideal size okay i want to get into you
when
before you were married is it true that
you were charged with a crime
and your defense was that you couldn't
have possibly committed the crime
because you were far too drunk
uh it was a college incident and it was
a student court
and they accused me of
causing damage with willful intent and
my defense was
that i was too drunk to be capable of
having any intent
ladies and gentlemen my dad
yeah dude and of course i don't have to
introduce you to scott randolph or paul
briskey
but i do want to thank you for being
here well it's great to be here and
i've watched enough of your podcast that
it's terrific to now be able to
participate in one
yeah do you watch every podcast no just
when mark cuban is on
well mark cuban mike tyson shaquille
o'neal jerry rice nice
all right so if dad's uh aware of and
interested in the guest we can count on
him listening
cool have you noticed like uh how are we
doing with the show
are we improving is it uh you know paul
i don't think i've
seen enough and i haven't looked at it
from the standpoint of
comparing i've either liked it or i
haven't liked it
and i've been focused more on steve's
interviewing skills
and it's really interesting the
differences
depending on the guest that he has right
i do believe that i've grown
substantially uh as a result of doing
this podcast
i think i still have a ways to go but
it's definitely getting better
well life is a journey and if you hadn't
grown some you'd be a failure
and uh the promise of future growth
keeps you going
absolutely and honestly i never
predicted that podcasting
would uh represent really just an
exercise in me improving my ability to
communicate
well it does it shows and that that's
the benefit i get from it above all
else yep and i just show my ass to the
world
a lot and i continue to do so but the
benefit is real you're evolving and
that's important
right so we established your background
with uh a clip that we recorded
either over or about exactly two years
ago
and uh you're you're a very impressive
guy
um and from here i think that
we should let the world in on our on our
history
right go forward okay let me ask you
uh how many times would you estimate
that you were called into school
to meet my teachers on
a day that was not actually designated
for meetings between parents and
teachers
there were many incidents some of them
by phone some of them by report card
but the one thing that was consistent
was that
steve is capable of so much more if he
only put some effort into it
that's that that was a mantra and it
used to be the teacher saying that
until the motley cruise story and
without
rehashing it i called every hotel in the
yellow pages to meet motley crew i
accomplished that
you took photos of me with the members
of motley crue
and then it turned into a curse for the
rest of my life he said
every time a report card came in every
time i was injured
son of steve if you would just show the
initiative
to you know to your schoolwork to fill
in the blank that you did to me
motley crue you could accomplish
anything yeah well you spent a whole
sunday afternoon
calling every hotel in the toronto
telephone book
and it took you until the end of the day
to get the right hotel
so that was initiative yeah and that was
lacking in every other aspect of your
life
right was that was that really the first
time you saw steve like
take any sort of real passion and
initiative for something
uh yeah
he had you know as a kid little league
baseball
i mean there was a lot of stuff when he
put his mind to something
you know he would go out and do it but
that was to me the most
impressive it was uh what grade were you
in when you did that
i was in eighth grade and you went to
school the next day and you're like
guess what dudes
i went to school the next day wearing my
girls girls girls uh concert
t-shirt which had like just a big
stripper bent over with her butt and a
thong
and uh they sent me home from school
that day to change my shirt
really yeah i was i was super proud of
that well the thing
the thing i remember was that the curve
started
our company had a you know skybox in the
maple leaf gardens
and nobody that the company would want
to go and see the motley crew
so i got the skybox and i got somebody
to smuggle in your recording equipment
we did we we we did it we brought it and
we went
now you i think you gave it to the
company driver and he
put it in ahead of time to the because
you wouldn't have been allowed in the
door of the gardens
with your recording equipment and i came
home as a surprise and i said steve
guess what
i got the sky box at the gardens
you got your recording in there and i
thought i was
super dad i really felt hot [ __ ] and
your immediate reaction was
[ __ ] dad that's lame who wants to watch
the crew in a skybox
yeah dude watching motley crue like
behind a plate glass window
sucks and then i said then i said
fine you get better seats on your
initiative
and i'll take you there and uh easy to
cancel the box
but if you want better seating than that
you've got to accomplish it
and that's where the initiative piece
came in whoa okay
that coupled with the fact that i saw
the day before the concert that motley
crue was in town and the news was
complaining that these rock stars in our
town
causing trouble and i was like wow
they're already here
but i think that's an old story we don't
need to rehash too much i think what's
what's interesting to me is that to make
clear what your job was and what the
company was
at that time like of course it was
nabisco
makers of oreos and and all kinds of
national biscuit companies what nabisco
means
and you were the president of nabisco in
canada yes
and it was a the nabisco skybox correct
and your uh job
with nabisco was born of
your previous job with rj reynolds
tobacco uh in between
what happened i joined rjr for the latin
america job
and then we moved back to london with
del monte
which was part of rjr and i did that
and then rjr including dalmati merged
with nabisco
and after the merger i ended up in
canada
uh running the canadian piece all right
how many countries have you been to
do you know off the top of your head i
don't know
you don't keep track i would say uh you
know
probably all of western europe uh all of
south america except chile
and bolivia uh guatemala nicaragua
costa rica and central america
and i guess a couple of trips to india
and
you went to russia i wasn't like two
weeks away from being born in russia
no you were two weeks away from being
born when you went to morocco
but you were the most traveled fetus uh
but but that that wasn't to do with the
job
we just happened to live in london and
your mom and i took a lot of short trips
to a lot of different places
because it was easy to do and at the
time relatively inexpensive
right what was the story with russia
there was like some
car chase or something something
something crazy
you got in the car chase we uh
your mom and i went to moscow for four
days with an american couple that we
were very friendly with in london
and we ended up uh in the bar in what
the time was a leading hotel it was
called the in tourist hotel in moscow
that was when russia was a completely
different place from what it is now
and somehow we got talking
to these two black guys uh from the
republic of chad
they told us that they you know were
working with the chad
embassy in moscow point was
one of them didn't speak any english so
your mama and i talked to them
primarily in french and bored the [ __ ]
out of our friends from texas
and then after not too long the older
brother
who was accompanied with a white russian
lady excused himself and disappeared
and shortly after that um
the younger brother who remained said
hey we got this great party tonight at
the chad embassy
do you want to go to the party and with
hindsight
he was obviously trying to create some
problems and
you know you know hook up with one of
our wives
the texas couple got into a fight
and they screwed off and went to bed and
your mom
had a couple of drinks and decided she
wanted to go to bed
and strangely she was accepting when i
said well [ __ ] i want to go to the party
at the embassy
so we're in this taxi driving across
moscow
and suddenly the taxi pulled to a stop
and what was supposedly the
embassy was this crappy looking
apartment building
and he went into this single room
apartment
with a naked light bulb hanging in the
center of the room
and the older brother was already in bed
with a white russian
and the younger brother wanted to kick
me out because
what the [ __ ] he didn't get what he
wanted and why should he worry about me
as crazy foreigner happily
the older brother you know climbed out
of bed and put on his pants
and went out into the street with me and
got me a taxi
uh to get back to the hotel and your mom
was sound asleep and i was able to get
in without waking her up
and life was very happy the next morning
wow
so there was no party they were just
trying no no there was no park no party
at all this was a guy trying to bone my
mom
is there even an embassy of chad in
russia
i i would guess there was but i don't
know
okay um now i remember mom
telling me about a time when you guys
smoked pot together
oh snap i just called out dad for
blazing hay
for firing up the doobage and
i might be about to call him out on
boning my mom
yeah well hey you know what i'm gonna
call myself out
for bone and this little hot chunk of
puss i got my girl
standing right next to me lux she's all
dolled up
looking fine and making me feel kind of
horny
you know when i'm feeling kind of horny
and i really want that extra
oomph you know what i do i take blue
chew
what's a blue chew it's a tablet that
has the same active ingredient as both
viagra
and cialis and what does it do when i
take it
it gives me a rock hard boner
frankly yeah plus this tablet
is a fraction of the cost of viagra and
cialis and it's chewable
and when i chew it my tongue turns blue
and when i show lux
my blue tongue what happens babe i just
start stripping
off my clothes i know it's go time yeah
have i ever let you down
after taking a blue chew no it is highly
effective
and appreciated yeah so how do you get
one
well you go to bluetooth.com and
remember that the promo code stevo will
help you out greatly
but what's important about going to
bluechew.com is that
it doesn't require any awkward visit to
a doctor you don't have to physically go
into any weird doctor appointment
because you just consult with one of
their medical providers right there at
bluetooth.com
and it's super simple and then the
things just show up in the mail
okay now how do you get an entire
month's supply
completely for free well you go to
bluetooth.com you use the promo code
stevo
you get an entire month's supply
completely for
free all you have to pay is five dollars
for shipping
and honey one more time how hard do i
bone you after i take a blue chew
so hard yes
okay so one more time three months
supply all you gotta pay is five bucks
go to bluetooth.com and use the promo
code stevo
all right now let's talk about my dad
getting baked
[Music]
and you insisted that uh that it had no
effect on you
but uh but mom said that that was
absurd it was laughable that after
smoking
the the marijuana that you guys like
wiped out all the food in the in the
pantry and the fridge
and then and then you vigorously
made love and that you're very very
stoned
well i'm saying you were stoned i'm
really glad that she used the word
vigorous
i i i don't remember eating all the food
but it was an experiment that was not
repeated
when and where was this this was in
london in uh
probably 1973 about the same time as a
russia trip
okay dad was into experiments
parties yeah what's going on ted
that's great what company were you with
at that point pepsi
pepsi yeah okay a more liberal company
than
nabisco no i'd say they were equally
liberal i mean
both of those companies were very very
high performance companies
you you delivered they treated you like
god you didn't deliver and you were out
the door
and uh i loved that environment
do they care that you're stoned half the
time
i mean you make these idiot remarks and
then you try to get a reaction
i mean we're all laughing he's doing his
job
ah so that was in london where of course
i was born
correct in 1974. correct you're already
working for
pepsi so if i understand it where my
older sister cindy was born in
connecticut
that's where you were working for
procter and gamble
no i worked for procter and gamble in
toronto
in toronto i left procter and gamble to
join a marketing consulting company in
connecticut
and from there i went to pepsico and
pepsico you you went to london
and uh and got promoted to the brazil
position when i was six months old and
so i moved from london to brazil when i
was six months old correct
and uh so then
we only lived in in brazil for what
about a year and a half
two two years so i was two and a half
years old when we moved
from brazil to venezuela correct caracas
venezuela
and uh that was because you got promoted
within pepsi
to not just all of brazil but central
america yeah actually brazil
had was was part of the
latin america group and i reported to a
boss in buenos aires
and when we moved to caracas they
divided that
into two halves and i had the half
that went from the border north port of
brazil
up to the south border of mexico so that
was an upgrade that was called
uh north latin america and yeah that was
a significant promotion
significant promotion so uh
i'm two and a half years old at this
point and um
i'm i'm speaking english with you guys
yeah i had been speaking portuguese in
brazil
and now i'm in caracas venezuela so this
is where i learned to speak spanish
correct
in nursery school correct yeah i went in
with the maids at home right
and uh when was it the first day
of nursery school that the mom picked me
up and they said there was a real
problem
oh yeah i uh
what was the problem well i forget the
word
tremendous tremendous yeah yeah yeah
yeah and at that time our spanish
you know was okay but need
needed work and tremendo
yeah and we both thought that was really
good i mean
right and then we asked somebody uh you
know i mean
you presumably weren't there mom picked
me up yeah and she told me the story
afterwards
she told me the story when the teacher
said what steve is
traumatized how is my son oh he was
tremendous yeah but nobody
there spoke any english so right all the
communication was in spanish
sir like you need to know that your son
is tremendous
mom's really pretty happy about this she
comes home to brag about it yeah she
takes the good news back to ted
you know hey how about that my son's
tremendous guys
and uh the the spanish speaking friends
said hey you know that's not um
tremendous like a storm like
like a hurricane like uh yeah like
like a piece of [ __ ] but not [ __ ]
cool
so that's you at three years old like
what could you have done
in there yeah right well the interesting
thing i remember
we were watching all you were watching a
lot of you know spanish language tv and
it was all uh
american programming with uh spanish
soundtrack dubbed in
and we moved up to connecticut it was
about two weeks
before we moved into our new house
and we stayed on holiday inn and we
chose it for its proximity to the house
and the school
and it was really kind of a tacky
holiday inn with you know cigarette
burns in the carpet and
you know crappy furniture and all the
rest of it and
mom told me that you know the first day
you're getting ready to go to nursery
school
and you turned to mom and said mom when
are we going to get to america
all right and and uh
yeah i was i was that was a problem
so i was a problem on day i was
tremendous on
day one of nursery school at two years
old
and and i was probably saying that was a
problem in every
in kindergarten first yeah like ted when
you're getting called to the school
to talk to the principal when steve's
you know in like middle school or
something what are those calls
for like what did steve do well they
were always taken
by his mother and so i got it second
hand
and i don't remember that many meetings
i remember
a lot of report cards and a lot of
conversations
um but
to the extent we went to meetings it was
basically the same old story now steve's
got so much more potential
and he doesn't use it and it's he's
disruptive in class
and he should be getting much higher
grades and what are you going to do
about it
right and we said all the appropriate
things and life went on without a whole
lot of change
so i'm curious like i'm sure all parents
go through like
uh just sort of fearing for your child's
future
or being or like what was in your head
like
were you like i don't know what this
kid's future's gonna be like or were you
optimistic like he'll figure it out like
what was your perception of
what steve's future was going to look
like never really got that far
thinking about it i mean we were always
living in the present okay
yeah putting out fires in the present
yeah
um so then uh
you know it's kind of moving through
grade school uh
you know and and we moved to miami when
i was in first grade i remember my first
day
of first grade that the classroom had a
uh
uh the whole wall was just a window
right because it was sort of like you
went it was an outdoor kind of a
campus and uh mom showed up to pick me
up
um like it's somewhat before the bell
rang to to release it so mom's standing
outside the window
and i'm like just i remember like
climbing on top of my desk and like
waving yeah
you know i was just like what the hell
but it was and then i just don't know
like i always
just had this super crazy over developed
need for attention
and that drove everything to this day
um and then uh so fourth grade
uh fourth grade still in florida we
moved to england again
how about that dude just like before you
leave fourth grade
that was the only teacher you connected
with where you got good grades
right yeah and you know i i forget his
name um
i but but he i think he was the only
male teacher you'd had
and uh he came to my football games yeah
and he's stan fenton yeah and he
he got he showed what could be
right and then it kind of went down the
tube when you got to london
yeah got to london okay so so we we
moved to london i'm in fourth grade i'm
nine years old
and uh and there was sort of an interim
apartment building that we lived in
while mom and dad were looking for a
house to get
and in this apartment building there was
this creepy like
handyman lived in the basement right
like uh
and i was just like down in the basement
nine years old
hanging out with this creepy handyman
and his like sidekick
like chick down there i think they were
like smoking doobies all the time i
don't even know what what kind of a
weird environment it was but i was down
there like most of the time okay
okay now these people sent me up to
my apartment with various videotapes of
like super like
gnarly horror movies one notably had
been banned in
england it was illegal to have and
they're giving me this was given it to a
nine-year-old it was called i
spit on your grave and like the the
premise of the movie was that this woman
had been raped gang raped
and then the rest of the movie is she's
going to murder
each and every one of the guys who raped
her and one of the guys when she's
murdering him she like kind of like
fake seduces him grabs his wiener and
cuts it off with a knife and throws it
in the sink
and so after viewing this videotape by
myself because i'm
very i liked supervision
you know mom and dad didn't know like
that i was down in the basement with the
creepy guy
and they didn't know that i was watching
these things on the bcr
band films and uh but the next day after
watching i spit on your grave
i show up in fourth grade class and they
have show and tell
anybody's anybody show and tell and i
said yeah
i got show and tell i had to tell you
about this great movie i watched this
guy got his dick cut off
blood everywhere it's great it's called
a spit on your grave i think it's banned
so that was definitely a time when you
got a call
and i i think i think i may have been
out of the country and mom might have
taken that call
yeah what no absolutely you were always
out of the country
dad was never around and mom was drunk
so the creepy mechanic fills in you know
one serious note to demonstrate how
[ __ ] up
the current world has become is that
that
movie that you watch that was banned
would be x-rated today
but it would be in broad distribution
you know what i don't i don't
know that uh that it was ever banned in
america i think it could actually very
much
like but
but there's so many people that are
[ __ ] up
because they spend all their time
watching this kind of [ __ ]
because it's so readily available and at
least in that era
and in england uh you know there is some
degree of control on it
yeah but the thing is that when you ban
something everybody wants it more yeah
everybody wants it more that was why i
was so thrilled that my uh my early dvds
were banned in ontario
so i was killing it ontario yeah yeah
what the early or just ontario i forget
if it was just one of them or something
but yeah banning stuff is gen
it's like when you tell your kid what
not to do you know yeah or what words
they can
say at the beginning of a tv show
it becomes mtv's biggest hit right and
you know what sucked about that fourth
grade situation was the superintendent
all of a sudden disappeared
yeah the guy the guy was gone i don't
know so what's okay so flash forward to
like high school are the
are you getting in the same type of
problems or different um
oh dude um you know what the
eighth grade ninth grade tenth grade
were probably my most
like well-behaved years and that was
because my passion was skateboarding
you know i wasn't into like getting i
mean getting in trouble i just wanted to
skateboard and
and i think that uh it instilled such
great
values in me because skateboarding with
like you know everything we talked to
tony hawk about
how like it's just it weeds out the
quitters you know it like really
isolates like just
you know kids that are willing to
sacrifice and work hard
and you know like all these crazy things
and um
then after uh tenth grade i quit
skateboarding and decided to become a
pothead yeah but i gotta i gotta stop
you in the skateboarding because
i remember fondly you know walking down
prince albert road with you
watching you attempt to ollie over soda
cans that were lying in their side
yeah they couldn't do it i stomped them
down and your your biggest
accomplishment
was when you could get over the vertical
yeah
sort of can and uh
we i guess wrongly trusted you
but you traveled all over london i mean
from age of 10
you were riding the london underground
system by yourself
right and uh you know pluses and minuses
it was a safer place then than it has
since become but you got independent
and you got self-confidence that's it's
very
very valid and notable that
in america for the most part uh
uh a young adult uh
life does not really begin with any
level
of real freedom until a a kid turns 16
years old and is able to drive
yeah but however when not even 10 when i
was
nine years old the public transportation
system
in london afforded me all of the freedom
that 16 years and older in america
get and i had all that freedom and i
exploited it at the age of nine yeah but
the other thing
you know with the skateboard when you
had the skateboard you went all over
london
yeah i mean you didn't just do it in the
local area and i'll never forget
uh royal oak not far from where he lived
by the
royal oak underground station they had a
purpose-built
skate park escape underneath underneath
the highway but uh
built for skaters and i said kind of
wishfully steve this is great why don't
you uh
use that more often uh and be closer to
home
and maybe less at risk and i don't know
if you're telling me the truth or not
but at the time i'll never forget you
looked me in the eye and
said dad that's one of the most
dangerous places in london
they found a dead body there not too
long ago i i don't doubt
that uh that they had found a dead body
it was certainly a dangerous
neighborhood but but the point is that
rather than being
upset i was impressed with the street
smarts that you developed
yeah and that made me feel even better
about you chasing around london
everywhere you went uh on youtube yeah i
think
that they clearly like to go skate the
ditch at royal oak that was like
hey let's get a group together so that
we're you know safety in numbers
and i and you know i didn't know that
so i i i gave full marks to you for
being a war on it
and now okay so now how about this like
a
junior year prom okay i'm i'm uh
in 11 i'm in 11th grade dad already
knows where this is going
you better believe the story my dad and
i are about to tell is awesome but do
you know what is
not awesome the fact that i recently got
maybe fatter than i've ever been why
because i had a full-blown
food relapse i got back on the sugar
with the candy and the cake and the
cookies
and it got ugly really fast plus my
heart rate variability took a serious
nose dive
and if you're wondering what's heart
rate variability it is a
crucial metric for indicating how fit
you are man
and i get the info from my whoop band
and my woop app
which happens to be the most
sophisticated fitness
tracking device and app in the world
tells you everything
and you know what i care about my
fitness and
my whoop band is helping me get
fit again yesterday i had a massive
skateboarding session
and my whoop app tells me yep that
significantly built up a cardiovascular
load yeah and i love a load
okay and i love my woop app and i want
you
to try it the woop band is completely
for free
what you do is you go to woop.com you
use the promo code stevo
sign up for a subscription and you get
off at checkout when you use the promo
code stevo this is going to tell you how
how well you're sleeping
it's going to tell you all kinds of
stuff and because i worked out so hard
yesterday
and had to be on set so early today i
really didn't get much sleep
and it tells me yep i really didn't
recover very much
i need to maybe get some rest tonight
and i know that because of my woot band
so if you want to get 15 off
at checkout you go to woop.com you use
the promo code stevo
and get active get fit and enjoy your
life now let's hear the story
i'm so excited for prom right and and uh
what i'm doing is i'm taking a
a a pack of cigarettes
and i dispensing with the cigarettes and
i'm rolling these
cone-shaped spliffs right these uh these
joints and with the cone shapes so that
every other one's upside down so that
they all fit perfectly into this pack of
cigarettes right
you love packing things yeah right and
uh
and i'm all excited i'm like and and i
got the drawer
like i've got the cigarette butts open
so you can see how they all fit together
great
sticking out with the twisted you know
like end
and it's open on display and in the
drawer which is also wide open
so dad for one reason or another mom
other than his mom
mom is in my room she looks in the
drawer she's looking at a box of joints
so she tells dad and uh and
you tell the story from here well we
didn't like it
and so clearly the only thing to do was
to confiscate the joints
and this was oh and didn't mom light one
to make sure it was pot i didn't know
that
that may be happening but anyway
i got the word i got the word and so
yeah i i got a hold of the offending
substance
and this was about if i remember
correctly
three or four o'clock in the afternoon
on the day of on the day of the prom
and i yeah i i just i knew you'd
spent your hard saved allowance money on
it
and i felt a little bit uncomfortable
with the economic
impact i said well chef if i give him
the money he's not going to be able to
go get any more so
i'll feel better about it and i was too
stupid i was too stupid to wait until
the next day
yeah dad you paid him back for the
we were talking about ten dollars value
no no no no it was uh
i mean at least 20 pounds no
come on no i wouldn't use the bottom's a
whole cigarette box full of joints
well maybe we didn't get all the joints
and we only got part of it and then
thank you for partying
and i think i think i i think i over you
profited yeah oh my god well you have to
take into account the time you took to
roll the joints
it's quite an expense yeah dad paid for
it and within like
half an hour i had a big block of hash
i love how ted you just couldn't handle
like the inefficiency of it you know
you're like this makes bad business
sense like we need to fix this
yeah oh yeah that was that was too much
so what you ran out gotta
block a hash and then yeah yeah i didn't
have time to roll it all into joints but
i
certainly replaced the actual drugs
in short order yeah and so then uh
and you know like i said i was a pretty
good kid it's just skateboarding all
through 10th grade
i was a b c student and then 11th grade
i decided
the first week of 11th grade i
found the stoners and i said hey i wanna
i wanna can i try pot
it wasn't like i was peer pressured into
it nobody presented it to me
i went looking for an opportunity to get
baked and i and i i smoked pot and i
smoked it the next day and then i was a
daily pothead
from the onset and i started taking acid
and i started drinking alcohol regularly
and my grades really took a serious nose
dive
and if it weren't for the fact that i
applied to the university of miami on an
early acceptance
deal i would had a lot of trouble
getting accepted in there because my
grades were just
you know falling off a cliff and when i
went to the university of miami it was
it was a problem right away
dad you said as a parent like uh
explain sort of what it was like you
know having
having me at the university of miami
well uh you'll probably want to say
about the tour of the school
i've been legitimately criticized for
trying to look at life
with the silver lining through the
rose-colored glasses
and i remember when we went to
university of miami uh
you know on the tour and we
walked out of the administration center
and you looked at me and said
dad i don't want to go here i will go
here
and we went back to london and one of
the requirements
i guess was with most schools still to
an extent
you had to write an essay yep and that
was a
huge issue for your sister and for most
other kids
coming through high school and uh you
told a story and it was one page only
i knocked it out and you knocked it out
and uh
it was sad but poignant
and uh probably impacted the approval
process
yeah i mean i remember uh the story i
wrote was about
how uh i think i think i said it was
it was you know 3 p.m and the school
bell rang
you know and and this uh third grade kid
was so excited and just got on his bike
sped all the way home because he had a
little league baseball game that day and
he was so stoked playoff game
yeah like a little league is he before
leaving for school that morning
this is a true story too i had laid out
my baseball uniform across my bed all
like particularly ready to go throw it
on and play the game so i got suited up
in my uniform and i went yeah hey mom we
got
time time for my game and mom was drunk
you know in bed and she says i'm not
driving you today
you know like and i'm not prepared to
handle this level of disappointment it
wasn't gonna it wasn't gonna
happen so what i did was uh in my
uniform i went over to the neighbor's
house and i rang the doorbell and the
neighbor the neighbor's mom was home and
i said hey you know
i'm in a spot i gotta get to my game can
you give me a ride i talked her into it
and i actually had a really strong
performance at that game
you know like i was awarded a star which
was sewn onto my
jersey for my performance in that game i
got a ride home
the moral of the story uh in in this
essay that i wrote was that
you know my mom's like an alcoholic you
know and uh
and something or other like you know i
was just like uh
and and and i i want to come to the
university of miami to really make
something to myself you know
like uh you know something or other
the irony being that i was like already
an
act of alcoholic and that when i got to
the university of miami
i would be so intoxicated and in so much
trouble in
such a short time that i would not last
for long
yeah so uh
i [ __ ] up when did you see steve's
like alcoholism kick in did you know
that he had a problem with drugs and
alcohol
the um dad's answer to every question is
well i wasn't in the country i heard
about it
no no i think it became apparent to me
in uh in toronto
um when i was in seventh grade
yeah yeah you you found a uh i stole a
bottle of wine
yeah and you got wasted and you puked
all over the place
and uh your mom was there to sort of for
the first
first responder and uh when i got home
that's when i was really worried because
concurrent with that you had a little
pup tent or something
and uh i ran away from um you you you
ran
about the equivalent of half a dozen
city blocks from home
and pitched your tent in a little ravine
behind the house
but uh i i made it further than that i
made it uh
like i did take one bus and get off i
didn't get on a second bus because
that's what i did every morning to get
to school
and i walked through this okay i thought
you were closer
and anyway that's how i twist i told my
sister my plans i said i'm gonna run
away i'm gonna live in this ravine
and uh and i set up my tent i was in the
tent you know i haven't run away now
mind you i ran away with no
money with no food why did you run away
because you got in trouble for the
bottle of wine god knows no i didn't run
away from
trouble with the word i didn't i had
nothing but that that that's when i
started to worry
right yeah and then and then london came
after that
and uh somehow when you were with the
skateboarding
things improved i kind of breathed a
sigh of relief and
thought we were out of the woods and
clearly we weren't
right so when did you realize you were
in the woods still
[Laughter]
maybe when my report card came back from
the university of miami and i
achieved over the course of the whole
semester a cumulative gpa
of 0.79 yeah what was it
well i i i i i said i looked for the
silver lining
and there was there was a good side of
that
you flamed out so fast i didn't piss
away a lot of money
useless education right we're gonna blow
it blow it quick
yeah yeah quick let's make that only uh
one year of tuition you know
it's obviously sad and
lest the wrong impression is being
created
we can talk about this now and laugh
that's right because it's behind us
and you've turned out fantastically well
but when i look back uh i don't think i
realized how scary it was
yeah and uh it's certainly uh
i don't want to convey the wrong
impression by laughing about it now
right
i mean we have we had a real uh
pretty heavy talk i remember i think it
was the night that the
reelection of george w bush was
unfolding in 2004
and we were talking about how uh
we were talking about how um
when i dropped out of the university of
miami i i had
zero communication with you for a full
six months you did not know where i was
in the world that's correct you heard
nothing about me
you didn't know if i was alive if i was
safe in fact i was having the government
test
dangerous drugs on me for money and you
didn't know that or anything
and uh and and i said to i said to you
about
that whole period of time where i was
off the radar
that uh i said uh something like
you know i said dad you weren't gonna
pay me
to be a piece of [ __ ] that wasn't doing
anything that you approved of and you
said
you didn't give me the opportunity you
know
which is pretty heavy you know almost
suggesting that he would have helped me
out if i reached out
but i had too much pride to reach out
and you know what
you're right i would have and with
hindsight
i value the pride and helping you out
would have been enabling that trend
100 it's like i have a philosophy about
parents who help out their kids
financially too much it's very much like
if you break a bone you got to have a
cast on that bone while it heals
you know like like like a kid is it
needs help like in order to become an
adult
but much like if the bone is healed and
you leave that cast on
then you don't need to cast because the
bone is healed and by having the cast on
your muscles
atrophy they become weak they become
useless and ultimately you're in much
worse position
and so many so many parents view
helping out their kids financially as
like some kind of a positive thing
when in fact it's very much just leaving
that cast on and
and it's you got a lame duck kid that
never learns how to
how to fend for themselves you know i uh
i guess it was after that time you were
uh back in london
uh i think it was no it was uh
uh connecticut no it was
uh just like getting the years straight
florida
and you were staying with your mom and
uh
i'll never forget uh she kicked me out
on christmas she kicked you out on
christmas morning
something and yeah i've always respected
her for that
and to this day i know i wouldn't have
the strength of character to do that
yeah it's tough what did you do on
christmas morning i did something
he came up we we had an apartment in
tequesta and you came
up and at that at that time
everything was closed down on christmas
day i don't know what
plan had existed before you showed up
but i remember we went to an ihop
to celebrate the christmas meal and i
think you i i forget what you stayed
with us
for a while and i forget what happened
after that
um i mean mom kicked me out
like a number of times how old are you
at this point uh at that time i would
have been
20 into 21. and uh it was just like look
you know
you're not willing to get a job you're
[ __ ] making a mess
you know you're acting like an [ __ ]
you say you're gonna do something you
don't do it like i've had enough get the
[ __ ] out
you know like i and uh yeah and i
totally deserved it
and i always um like ended up on
someone's sofa or something
you know how old would your mom been at
that point in time
uh if i was 20 21 this was interesting
um i'm not that quick
what year what year was that that would
have been 1994.95
like 40 or 50. uh she uh
was she born or how old would she when
steve was born
i mean i don't know let's not waste our
valuables but probably close to your age
right now
i mean i know that she was what was she
50 when uh
she turned 40 when we were in toronto
which which
um so she would have been late 40s so
basically your age
just think like could you imagine being
in that position now telling a 21 year
old kid to get the [ __ ] out of your head
like your own kid you know
i mean hey if you baby them you bury
them you know and
i i probably sympathize with my dad
because you know as we were talking
about
i went ahead and got a vasectomy because
i just don't even
like i couldn't stand to have a kid and
uh
you know i i liken it to having you know
one's
heart outside of their body like
vulnerable and it's like
it's just i i i think that i have such a
profound respect for the idea of
creating a human being
uh that i i can't bring myself to do it
real quick i'm just curious to know what
kind of person you were like when you
get kicked out were you like
why or were you just like all right fine
[ __ ] i was like yep
touchy that's funny yeah i don't think i
i
never fought it i never held it against
her i didn't i wasn't doing anything to
deserve the
the the roof over my head and and i was
an insult to
her her generosity it's cool that you
know go ahead
one of the ways that you really screwed
me up uh
you never missed an opportunity
to remind me about how much time i spent
traveling and wasn't there during your
growing up years
and you never appreciated that i really
busted my ass to get home every weekend
i mean there were times when i'd fly
down to
uh rio and spend a night in the airplane
and
you know two days there and then fly
back in the airplane and
go to the office on friday and be home
in the on the weekend
and and you know i understand from your
perspective
that i was away a lot i was never mad
about it you never bet but it was always
a dig
all right and and it created a a bit of
a complex
that made me more vulnerable to uh uh
exploitative enablement okay
all right so if so you probably wouldn't
have thrown steve out because
you there would almost be this like
guilt with it you're like oh you know
i wouldn't have thrown steve out anyway
i don't think right but
i think i think i behaved somewhat
differently
in the latter period you know as a
result of these frequent reminders
that i'd kind of been a shitty parent
because i was a wasteland i mean
that you uh
what are you gonna do you were you were
you were a boss hey you were a boss you
were a baller
you were killing it and that required
world travel
on a very regular basis and to your
point about making it home on the
weekends
to me that's just pure comedy because
because
because the reality was that when dad
wasn't home my mom
really did her best to squeeze her
drinking in while you were gone
and pull it together for when you got
home so not only were you gone but mom
was drunk and i just
was a lawless little kid with zero
supervision okay and then when you did
come home on the weekend
recognizing that you had been gone you
would try to overcompensate by being
really disciplinarian on the weekend
and so it was just such a completely
inconsistent thing
you can't have like free rain during the
week and be like really late
for the weekend that that level of
inconsistency is just
absolutely futile okay but
but moving on to sunshine and happiness
moving on to sunshine unhappiness you've
turned out well
you've got a great career you're smart
articulate
motivated driven hard-working i mean son
of a [ __ ]
if you evaluate the results rather than
the root it took together well
then thank you for all those kind words
i also you know added going back to the
to the vasectomy remember
the first time that i ever told you i
remember it was like jackass was was
pretty
pretty early on and i think it would
have been maybe 2003
the first movie had come out now it's
like wow we're this big
like this number one movie wow and i'm
just thinking what are big huge ideas
and i said to dad when i said dad i got
this great idea
it's called the vasectomy olympics you
know it's like i'll get a vasectomy and
i'll go running through like a crazy
obstacle course and it'll be great and
dad
like you're not a particularly emotional
guy you're very logical
you know like and that was one time you
got fairly emotional you said oh no
don't do it well i don't remember i
think the uh
vasectomy olympics came in a lot later
when you implemented in puerto rico
i remember i remember i ended up doing
it almost 20 years ago yeah but
i don't remember that that that title i
just remember
i know it was going to be olympics from
day one and i said well maybe you
thought it but i
i said dad it's great if you're the only
person who enters the competition you
automatically win
you can't argue that logic you know but
so you you were
you were hoping for grandchildren from
dad was uh
no no no no no no no no i um
i've just said that and his his sister
frankly have enriched my life and i
thought
not having kids uh he'd be missing out
on something
right and and to that i always said dad
i hear you but you got kind of [ __ ]
lucky you were so close
to that worst thing that could ever
happen to a human being which is a
parent losing a child
i didn't know real realize how close
that came until
i mean who knows maybe we're close or
not but
like they're that like you danced with a
lot of heartache and a lot of like
catastrophic tragedy
tragedy that i'm not willing to to roll
the door i understand that
i'm not willing to roll the dice on that
and um
what's crazy what's crazy is like uh you
know you're used to
weed and alcohol and maybe cocaine like
not not but like hearing people do drugs
and then when you hear
steve's like drug breakdown you're like
ketamine like he's doing
horse tranquility i think it's probably
safe to say dad's never laying eyes on
the cannon i don't mean to say that but
like the norm of drugs you know
you've heard about cocaine i was not
into that no no
to be clear i'm not saying that you were
i'm sorry like i saying like you know
you've heard about people doing it in
the movies but like when you hear of
steve
breakdown dad dad actually was
with me brought me to the rehab to check
me in
and was sitting there in the room when
they did their
orientation process to to the intake
and they said okay whatever your drug
history what are your drugs and dad
for the first time was hearing this list
of drugs and there was like [ __ ] he
never even heard of in his life
do you remember what the drug breakdown
would have been like yeah like pcp
nitrous oxide ketamine you know like
video head cleaner like you know like
what the [ __ ] like
it was uh you know i mean you remember
that yeah
vividly and you you're skipping over
what
i think was one of the toughest but one
of the best decisions in my life
you were having your final breakdown
right and you were sending you were
sending emails to half the world
talking about how you were going to
drive a motorbike through your apartment
everybody knows that but what they don't
know is that when knoxville organized my
intervention
he reached out to you and he said mr
glover we're organizing an intervention
for
for your son and we really want you to
be there maybe need you to be there
and dad said i said no
and i thought really hard about it and
uh with hindsight
i was absolutely right steve and i had a
good relationship
then with one exception he wouldn't
allow me to talk about his personal life
and i know there's no i mean about the
drinking and all that
i would not let you our relationship was
on my terms
yes because i didn't i didn't i wasn't
financially dependent on you like
i could have ostensibly just cut you out
of my life and been fighting yeah so i i
uh reasoned to think correctly that if
i'd been there
you and i would have been in the center
of the room shouting at each other and
all your jackass buddies would have
been neutralized in dead silence
so i told knoxville and and dr drew
called me too and i said the same thing
to drew i said uh
you know i'm going to come out but i'm
not going to come for the intervention
because his jackass friends
will do a much better job without me
than they could possibly do
with me yeah and i think that that was
absolutely right and so then they locked
up the psych ward and then i
agreed in the psych way to go to the
rehab and you were with me at the rehab
absolutely and
and while we're checking into the rehab
dad says to me says you know
what like once once we get this behind
us you know like once you know you do
this and
and i said dad's never going to get
behind us you know ours or once we once
once we fix this dad this doesn't get
fixed i said dad i'm a drug addict i'm
an alcoholic that's never going to
change
it's going to be the rest of my life and
the fact that you were married mom for
years and you still don't understand
that is [ __ ]
you know like i i all of a sudden like
that was
day one of rehab and uh just because you
knew like
even staying sober it's just a lifelong
struggle about it and my experience
with my mom yeah and i said dad i said
dad i'm here because i'm gonna take this
really seriously and uh and if you're
gonna
uh if you're gonna not get in the way of
it i need you to
i need you to sign up to be a part of
al-anon and stuff
so dad signs up for al-anon i i went to
regular al-anon meetings in both london
and florida
for at least a year yeah and then he dad
says to me he says i don't get it he
says all these people in these meetings
you know like
they seem to be there for for their own
benefit and
and i'm fine like i don't need any help
i'm just here to support you
and i say okay dad next time why don't
you just hand me a beer and a joint
no no no i i i got one thing out of
al-anon that i'll never forget it was in
florida
and uh there was a woman who was
probably in her 60s and her husband
you know i'm not sure if he was in
recovery
or if he was still struggling but she
said something i'll never forget she
said
you know if you're living with somebody
who is mentally ill
you cannot avoid becoming mentally ill
yourself correct
and boy that resonated with me that
correct yeah
and uh and and of course everything
worked out
uh this is so far so good one day at a
time and we're in a great place
but but i i want to like just go back
to where i i flunked out of the
university of miami you don't hear from
me for six months and then when
when i do show back up on the radar i
i'm homeless sometimes at mom's house
sometimes she's kicking me out
and uh my whole story is i'm gonna
become a
crazy famous stunt man this is gonna
it's gonna be awesome
and you uh tried to talk me out of it by
right yeah but yeah i uh i remember i
was in london
and the bbc had a
cinema film museum or archive or
something
i spent probably a couple of hours there
reading about stuntmen and technology
and got copies of a bunch of articles
that
said very clearly that in the
foreseeable future there weren't going
to be any stuntmen
because camera technology would make
them obsolete
right i very proudly
shipped all these clippings off to you
and that was before internet
so it went by snail mail and we hooked
up on the phone
a week or so after the fact and i said
hey did you read the stuff i sent i mean
this is really good stuff i mean you
gotta
think ahead yeah like you need a new
plan because stuntman
isn't a thing and and your answer was
okay
i'll just recruit a bunch of crazy guys
and have a traveling circus doing stunts
and people will pay to see us around the
country
and dad likes to say that that's sort of
what happened but
that is sort of what happened right i
mean you did a tour you and i
ended up doing that i ended up doing
that yeah for sure but uh but so dad was
not supportive of my initial
uh you know the pursuit of uh
of fame and fortune to be a stuntman
because
sorry was that mostly because you
thought there is no success
in that or was it that like oh that's
not
admirable that's dangerous no no no no
no
it was it was the former i mean you know
everything was so [ __ ] up i was
thinking short term then
and it seemed to me the most compelling
uh rationale
was that hey this is something that
doesn't have any future you're the one
that's going to suffer so rethink it
right got you yeah and uh and and
i i i was homeless for for still more
like years i i wasn't getting anywhere
but i was
filming what i could when i had a camera
a lot of times i had to borrow a camera
but i was filming what i could and
nobody cared
and then i ended up getting into clown
college and dad wasn't
even behind the clown college thing
really like uh i mean you weren't maybe
aggressively against it but you didn't
you're like what great now my stone's a
[ __ ] clown like uh
you weren't in love with it you weren't
in love with it and you weren't in love
with the whole stunt thing
but but and this is really important and
this is gonna
really be what all of this culminates in
because uh it's so special to me
which is that before
i got anywhere with all of that stunt
talk
and all of the everything that i wanted
to do like even though
dad wasn't supportive in the beginning
it was before
i had accomplished [ __ ]
before i had any recognition
before i had made any money dad
took like his own initiative
to have a conversation with me where he
said
hey man you know i gotta i i gotta
do you remember what you said yeah uh uh
and and from experience i uh
came from a family of academics and i
was the only one that went in the
business
and completely different you know apples
to oranges
but i remember my father saying to me uh
you know i really don't care
ted what you do as long as you find
something you enjoy
and you do it to the best of your
ability and those were about the same
words i
used with you you made reference to that
con that talked to you
you said you said hey i remember i
remember like this you said
hey um you know i i want to acknowledge
you know i want to tell you that i feel
i've really done a disservice to you
by discouraging you in this this
path you know that you that you've
clearly committed yourself to and so he
says he says
you haven't you you certainly didn't
choose for yourself a path
that i would have chosen for you but now
that you're clearly committed to it
uh you know i want you to know that you
have my
you know i i pledge to support you and i
just want you to be happy and be the
best what you do and he said that your
dad had a very similar
conversation so dad pledged to support
me
in my pursuit to become a stunt man
before
there was any glimmer of hope
before that and that put wind in my
sails and then uh
at the time there was this show called
real tv where they were looking to
license home video footage of notable
things happening
it was real tv caught on camera and i
saw the commercial and it said
that real tv if you have any footage
that you think we might want to see
you know like here's the number call us
up send it on in
and and i called them up and i said oh i
don't have footage that you might want
to see
i have footage that you need badly
you're
you're hurting for what i got yeah and
uh and sure enough i sent them the tape
and they sent me back this uh
they called me back yeah we love the you
on fire doing the flip
breathing the fire off the roof of the
building and
i was like i remember being indignant is
that all you want out of everything i
see
you want that one thing and uh they said
yeah we'll give you uh
was 500 bucks for exclusive license
yeah we uh we own it you don't own it
anymore right right
wow i don't know if i love that i don't
[ __ ] i called dad
the first the first contract i ever had
to negotiate on any level and dad was my
first call said dad
you remember that call huh yup were you
were you at work when he called you
dad had retired i think by that time i
think uh i wasn't at work
i think i had yeah or i was i was
working part-time as a consultant but
and what do you say well i was all dad
dad dad's exclusive
and dad said hey say you know take a
breath calm down
it sounds like this exclusivity is a
deal breaker for you or it sounds like
you don't like the excuse
he says it's really simple you know you
figure out at which point it's a deal
breaker you figure out what you're
comfortable with you draw your line in
the sand and you stick to
it you tell it he says why don't you
tell him you don't want to give him
exclusive right so you'll license
it non-exclusively so you still own it
and that you need a thousand bucks
instead of 500.
it's that simple so i told them that's
what i wanted and that's what i got
nice and given that i had dad in my
corner i can't believe i didn't get
better
jackass contracts well before you say
that i think i think we
worked that out because he got paid next
to nothing for the
first thing and that's right i've
learned is paying your dues in hollywood
but i remember reviewing your first
paramount contract
it would it would have been uh mtv
whatever it was
and uh they had language in there that
would have prevented you from doing
anything
except jackass right and at that point
you weren't wildly successful yet
but you were making modest income from
your videos
and you had that very crazy uh spring
tour stuff
where all you did was get drunk and
swear on the stage and everybody loved
you
uh but you were making some money right
and so i would have been allowed to do
that
so yeah you wouldn't have been allowed
to do any of that so i said hey get rid
of that language
and i'm proud of you because you know we
got rid of that language you had a clean
contract that let you do the other
things
and i just wonder how many uh first time
ever wannabes
that are given uh an opportunity to sign
up with mtv
go back to the corporate lawyers and say
[ __ ] this you gotta remove this language
or it won't sign
right i mean who knows like do you
remember doing that were you like i
don't want to take that out or if they
don't use me for the movie
that that was that the movie or that was
the tv series yeah so even even
you're like here's my chance i have this
contract
if i stand up for myself am i gonna [ __ ]
myself or what's like the principle
there i mean
i think the dad like uh gave me
confidence to do things like that
you know and that's what's so special is
that from the beginning
from the very first contract i ever had
dad was in my
dad pledged to support me and [ __ ] a
he did
you know and and this this is something
that i've said many times and i just
feel myself getting choked up every time
i say it and particularly now
but it gives me such gratitude it gives
me such just
intense just gratitude to be able to say
that that i
what's your relationship with your dad
like people might ask i just [ __ ] my
i have a great relationship with my dad
and i don't have
a great relationship with my dad because
i'm successful
i am successful because
i have a great relationship with my dad
and that's a big ass distinction
i think there are a lot of people who uh
who are successful
and uh and then everyone jumps on the
bandwagon you know
sure and that's not the case like uh i
[ __ ] love my dad
and and here he's sitting with those 78
years old
and and and nothing gets by him it's
like
it's it's it's really damn impressive
uh how sharp you are and scary as hell
because
there is dementia in the family and uh
and dad dad's 100 percent here sharper's
attack
and the idea that uh dad's not always
gonna be here
it scares the [ __ ] out of me like of
course i can't have a kid because i
don't even know
what i would ever do without my without
my dad hmm you know beautiful
[ __ ] i love you dad i love you too yeah
in spite of all the [ __ ] that happened
that's about how you put him how about
that man
like i'll be serious here for a sec like
my dad's not gonna be around forever
hell none of us are gonna be around
forever
but that podcast i just recorded with my
dad
will be around forever and that makes me
just feel
really really like warm and good
and for those of you who hung in there
and checked out the whole podcast
more than ever i want to say thank you
for sticking around to the end because
uh
[ __ ] that meant a lot to me it really
did
and uh i'll tell you since you stuck
around this long
we're on the set of jackass folks and
it's [ __ ] badass okay
thanks
[Laughter]